à l'école les enfants de 4 ans à la
maternelle sont surnommés les petits ici
au centre de la petite enfance ce sont
les grands si leur milieu de vie est
différent le réalité elles se
ressemblent
pendant que les enfants arrivent
graduellement au cpe de 7h à 9h et
s'amuse avec des jouets ceux de la
maternelle 4 ans font leur entrée en
classe
à 8h15 et dessine jusqu'à 8h30
[Musique]
dix enfants au maximum peuvent se
retrouver dans un groupe en cpe contre
17 à la maternelle quatre ans presque du
simple au double c'est parti nous sommes
mardi le zoo
l'enseignante accompagné d'une
éducatrice spécialisée préparent la
journée et fait quelques exercices
ludiques bientôt 9 heures c'est l'heure
de la collation puis des ateliers des
jeux et d'une petite histoire au même
moment au cp1 la journée prend
tranquillement forme avec la présence
d'une éducatrice à l'enfance est ici à
temps plein d'une éducatrice spécialisée
parce que les besoins particuliers sont
grands mais ce n'est pas ainsi dans
toutes les garderies est ce que tu te
rappelles la journée après la lecture
d'une recette pour concevoir du sable
coloré les enfants enfilent un tablier
et s'attelleront à la tâche
donc on sait c'est blaise qu'ils
connaissent pour les amener un peu plus
loin de l'activité où on a utilisé les
quantités comme lézardrieux faire des
mains et on mesurer il on compte donc
tout ça c'est à travers leurs jeux leurs
expériences qu'acheter des maps entier
dont cpe qu'à la maternelle 5
compétences doivent être développées à
travers les activités les dimension
affective physiques et motrices social
cognitives et langagière l'apprentissage
partagé parce qu'il ne veut pas les
ateliers se sont déjà en quelque sorte
c'est comme ça qu'on essaie estimé dans
toutes les sphères de développement on
essaie de voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut ou
on peut pas chez nous les enfants dans
leurs zones de développement
les amener un peu plus loin dans la
réflexion mais où toutes les autres amis
sont avait d'avoir fini nous aurons là
moi est de supporter l'enseignant je
suis handicapé mon premier rôle les
émotions
le tout se déroule au quart de tour à la
maternelle jusqu'à 10 heures 43 ou le
service de garde prend la relève jusqu'à
la fin du match
bonjour bonjour comme un ça va
le cadre scolaire impose une routine
beaucoup plus serrée aux élèves
comparativement à lagardère on n'est pas
rigide sur la durée du moment c'est ça
le l'avantagent d'avoir toute une
journée avec l'enfance toi qu'est ce que
tu as aimé
au cpe après leur retour sur l'activité
de sable il est temps d'aller jouer
dehors jusqu'au dîner qui sera servi sur
place vers 13 heures les enfants passent
au brassage d'en avant de faire la
sieste à la maternelle l'enseignant
entreprend la charge de ses élèves
sortis à l'extérieur suivi d'une
activité au gymnase ça plus la tenue
c'est fort plus ça va être facile a pris
à ce niveau là
les enfants reprennent leur souffle à 14
heures pour la sieste puis retour à la
maison ou au service de garde
à 15h15 les enfants dorment dans
l'intervalle plus longtemps au cpe et
parfois le réveil semble plus difficile
pour certains
après une histoire retour au jeu période
propice pour prendre à part des enfants
ayant des troubles d'apprentissage connu
tout chez ceux où cpe depuis la
pouponnière l'éducatrice spécialisée
joue ici un rôle clé que par exemple les
pierres sont que des besoins en finale
contre que j'étais avec tout ce matin
mais on était en jeu lips matin et c'est
lui qui décide et ce à quoi ont joué et
moi j ai travaillé là font tous deux des
petites de ton temps d'intervention en
orthophonie
à travers ces jeux mais contrairement
aux écoles les cpe ne bénéficient pas
sur place de services spécialisés comme
une orthophoniste ou un psychoéducateur
d'ailleurs le mérite de la maternelle 4
1 et d'offrir des services gratuits à
des enfants qui normalement demeurerait
à la maison surtout dans les milieux
défavorisés
oui je dirais qu'il y ait une différence
mais par contre quand ils sont aussi
rares cpe qui est bien éducatif l'enfant
va bien s'intégrer occident
l'objectif des deux services demeure
finalement le même faire ce qu'il ya de
mieux pour l'enfant c'est la poche dans
son encadrement qui diffèrent